welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and venom let there be carnage's
sticky thwhips to spiderman no way home
just got stickier with rumors of a
mind-blowing let there be carnage
post-credit scene confirmation from
venom 2 director andy circus that
spider-man and venom will meet and tom
hardy showing up in a spiderman no way
home production hat while it looks like
snacking on some haribo gummy bar ends
hope they're not the sugarless kind
because then we'd be looking at some
sticky thwhips and whippy shits but does
any of this confirm eddie brock venom
crossing over with spider-man in no way
home along with all of our favorite
tumblr gifts i'm gonna break down
everything we've just learned and the
complicated logic of what sony is trying
to do by whipping all these characters
together okay sticky flip one in the
past week preview screenings of venom
let there be carnage have elicited some
social media chatter of a reportedly
jaw-dropping post-credit scene that you
have to see in theaters but what's weird
about this is journalists and critics
who screen the movie early reportedly
saw no post-credits scene which by the
way for my collection sony also did for
the first venom film in 2018 so this
post-credits scene may have just been
attached to the special fan screening in
the uk whatever the source of this rumor
it seems like sony wants die hard fans
to be tweeting about an insane post
credit scene to let there be carnage
sticky flip 2 the movie's director andy
circus did an interview with ign who
asked him about venom meeting spider-man
look that's that's the question on
everyone's lips they want to know when
venom is going to meet spider-man
personally it's never going to happen
i'm only joking of course it's going to
happen um it's happened
it's going to happen of course it's
going to happen but it depends when you
want to get there in terms of his venom
franchise circus suggested there was
more to explore first from other
villains in the ravencroft institute as
well as toxin meaning detective mulligan
in this movie is confirmed to become the
symbiote toxin as in the comics and then
stickythwb3 tom hardy met with director
lynn oding in which odin posted to
instagram in his sense deleted wow maybe
because it showed tom hardy wearing a
production hat from spiderman no way
home oh my god behind those ass blasting
demon bears reflected in the mirror is
that kidding this is just a woman taking
the photo of this apparently black hat
wearing party or lids reunion who knows
production gear like this is typically
given to cast in crew who worked on the
set of a particular film a star like tom
hardy could have just picked one up from
like a sony contact or won it in one of
those arm wrestling matches that he
forces pas into i was in warrior don't
forget it who's next oy bird bones give
me that hat yeah warrior but this does
indicate hardy possibly visited the set
of spiderman no way home either in an
acting capacity or maybe even to the
film's post-production offices to record
audio as the voice of venom so is venom
going to be in spider-man no way home
and what's this super secret
game-changing post-credits scene that
sony is entrusting to fans but not to
professional critics who could lose
their jobs if they were to spoil stuff
now i don't want to concern you too much
but you got some enemies out there my
friend because the ice golem and the
fire knight are just begging for you to
defeat them you can get on that by
downloading this video's sponsor read
shadow legends use the links below to
download raid to your mobile phone or
your pc what i like about the game is
how you can mix and match artifacts on a
champion to totally change the way they
fight and adapt them to different parts
of the game and there's a recognizable
new legendary champion in game right now
it's ninja he's got a katana a bow and
an arrow and he controls both ice and
fire he looks incredible he is an
absolute beast in battle against bosses
especially the spider or clan boss every
one of his skills has something extra
for boss fights and he gets stronger the
longer a battle goes ninja is available
for free right now so everyone can get
him but he's only gonna be available
until october 15th he's a super limited
edition champion and once that day comes
you'll never be able to get ninja again
this month raid released a doom tower
update with two new bosses to take on
astronics the dark fae and bomb all the
dread horn along with other cool updates
this month is packed with awesome events
including one with a brand new feature
super raids super aids lets you double
up your rewards from hitting dragons and
speed up your progress you don't want to
miss this if you want to get a huge head
start in raid all you have to do is hit
the link in the description or scan my
qr code and you'll get an epic hero
chonoru who is amazing in the doom tower
200 000 silver one xp boost one energy
refill and one ancient shard so that you
can summon an awesome champion as soon
as you get in game all of this treasure
we'll be waiting for you right here
and once you're in you can find me and
game under the name new rock 2020 and if
you're fast you can join my clan and
it's that easy just click the link in
the description and i will see you in
the game well i think based on andy
circus using future tents to assure
vitamin spider-man's inevitable meetup
that eddie brock and peter parker
probably will not actually meet face to
face in venom let there be carnage or in
its post-credits scene but when it comes
to the timeline of all this circus can
only really speak to the venom franchise
and a possible venom 3 that he might be
a part of so i do think if we are to
trust the excitement of the viewers who
reportedly did see this post-credits
scene that the scene might feature some
acknowledgement by venom and or eddie of
the existence of peter parker or jk
simmons j jonah jameson in their world
for example a message from eddie brock's
daily bugle server from this rogue
editor john jameson saying he's got a
huge story and he's got a break off to
start an online news show or eddie
witnessing jameson's peter parker report
from the far from home post-credit scene
the one that seemed to be playing on
every screen in the no way home trailer
which would lead to a brief cameo by
venom in no way home just because every
other sign points to sony wanting to
bring every major spider-burst character
into no way home and if they can make
alfred molina doc ock and willem defoe
green goblin work what's one more the
movie is called no way home and i just
think these folks are all gonna wake up
to realize that they're now in a
slightly altered reality with no clue
how they got there leaving them with
literally no way home now you may be
thinking this doesn't really make sense
right i mean i wake up most mornings
thinking that the daily bugle in venom's
universe is a print newspaper the one in
the mcu is an online infowar style show
but weirdly venom let there be carnage
uses the same daily bugle print logo
from the sam raimi trilogy and those
films already had an eddie brock venom
played by topher grace it was just clear
that sony never expected us to overthink
it this much from the moment j jonah
jameson showed up in the mcu played by
jk simmons a character whose peter
parker was supposed to be toby maguire
not tom holland remember back to summer
2019 when we saw jk simmons show up on
screen we all cheered no one cared about
it until we got back to the refrigerator
that's why they call it refrigerator
logic ever since the spider-man no way
home trailer came out many of us have
assumed that it was doctor strange's
spell and or peter parker tampering with
it that caused this multiverse collision
of characters from separate film
universes but that doesn't explain
simmons as jameson which was already the
case before the spell and is arguably
just as weird as molina returning as doc
ock but marvel and sony do have a
convenient way out when it comes to
justifying their multiverse logic
specifically in the way loki rewrote the
rules of all this because when loki
ended by breaking up the multiverse the
implication of he who remains monologue
is that the multiverse was already in
the process of fracturing several
minutes before loki stabbed he who
remains he heard a rumble of thunder and
then sensed that the sacred timeline had
derailed which an exterior shot showed
us and he claimed to suddenly have no
idea what would happen next
we just crossed
the threshold
now i have no idea no idea how the rest
of this is going to go the loki writers
explained time and all of history
actually occurs simultaneously from the
perspective of he who remains so when it
comes to concepts like causality an
event in the past causing an event in
the present that's not how it works when
it comes to the tva and he remains
anyone in the citadel the sacred
timeline has already been in a state of
unraveling for all time always meaning
all past mcu logical lapses could be
explained as glitches in the multiverse
matrix leaving us with mandela effect
false memories of edward norton and of
terence howard and yes of jk simmons
playing the same man in different
universes simmons jameson is proof that
the multiverse has already collided and
so doctor strange's eagerness to help
peter parker with that dangerous spell
wasn't the origin of the multiverse
crisis it's about to take over the mcu
but instead strange's attempt to fix a
multiverse crisis that has already been
underway a fix that is just gonna make
things worse and nosedive into a
multiverse of madness so the mcu is not
about to break into a multiverse it has
already been a broken multiverse since
the beginning or that might just be how
sony and marvel oversimplify how tom
hardy got that free hat to avoid having
to pay for a pa's broken bird bones
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you